All right,
now that we've got the first demo loaded
up let's see what we've got here.
Well first what we've got is a README
file that actually contains the text
version of everything I've said so
far this level.
So if you need a refresher,
well you know where to find one.
To find the real meat
of the demo though,
let's open up the the TODO
pane down at the bottom.
Find a nice entry that says
TODO: Start here to learn more about
ApplicationListener and ShapeRenderer.
Sounds good.
Let's close the rest of these panes so
we have some room to work with.
If you open up this file
on your own machine,
you may notice that there's a whole
bunch more comments in here.
And again, that's more or less the text
version of what I'm about to tell you.
So the entry point into your
code that you write for
a game is a class that
implements ApplicationListener.
ApplicationListener has six required
methods that we'll walk through.
We've also inserted logging messages
that fire when each of those methods
is called.
So in this demo, first thing,
we're setting up a tag so
that we can identify our log messages.
And then we declare
a private shape renderer.
Create is the first one of the required
methods on an application listener and
that's basically where you do anything
you do in a normal constructor.
This will get called when
the host application is ready for
your ApplicationListener to come alive.
And of course, this is where we
initialize our shape renderer.
Immediately after our
application listener is create,
resize will be called to let
us know how big the screen is.
We won't be doing anything
with resize just for now, but
next level we will be using it to make
sure our camera doesn't go out of whack.
Next, we have the dispose method.
Now, you might be thinking this is Java,
don't we get automatic
memory management?
I thought garbage
collection was a thing.
Well, while it's true that Java can
usually be relied upon to clean up
your memory for you, a garbage
collection event takes a long time.
And when you have a game that trying
to render itself 60 times a second,
a garbage collection event can easily
make you drop a whole ton of frames.
That makes it look like the game is
just frozen and users don't like that.
So, there's a number of places where
we have to manage our own memory.
In this case, when our application
listener receives a call of dispose,
we should dispose of any
resources that we are using.
All right, the render method.
This is the real heart of the operation.
This gets called every time
our game should draw itself.
So, you know how I said we didn't
have to talk to OpenGL directly?
Well, that's mostly true.
These two lines clear
the previous screen.
These lines get repeated pretty much
verbatim at the start of every render
method throughout this course.
The first line tells OpenGL, hey,
what's the background color?
In this case it's black, that's opaque.
And the second line actually tells open
GL to go ahead and clear the screen.
All right, then we tell shape
renderer to start a new batch and
we pass in the shape
type we want to draw.
In this case we want to draw points.
Then we draw point at location 100 100.
So that's going to be 100 pixels
up from the bottom of the screen,
100 pixels right of
the left of the screen.
And then, we've got to remember
to end our shape renderer batch.
Pause is the second to last of the
required application listener methods.
And it gets called right before
our application is disposed of.
It can also be called when our app goes
offscreen and is no longer active.
This will usually happen in Android
when you hit the home button.
Pauses where we want to save anything we
want to persist about the game like how
many lives the player has left.
Resume gets called if the game comes
back to life after being paused.
Again this is pretty much
an android specific thing and
we'll talk much more about this later.
All right so we expect this code to
draw a single point to the screen.
Let's give it a try.
All right, it's not much,
but there we go.
We've got a single point illuminated.
It's kind of pretty kind of
like a star in the night sky.